it just seems like we need a break i
think that
after 20 seasons that's more than we
ever would have expected we didn't even
think we'd get to season two we didn't
think anyone would be into
watching a show about our crazy family
but in order to
figure out what our next journey will be
like we have to close this chapter and
say goodbye to keeping up with the
kardashians
kim kardashian opens up about walking
away from keeping up with the
kardashians after
20 seasons and reveals what kanye west
thought about the whole thing
you just gotta roll with it on keeping
up with the kardashians
the famous family sits down to talk
privately about what they want to do
with the show going forward
and they come to the conclusion it's
time to call it quits
all in favor say aye aye
aye majority rules
i okay decision made and before sharing
the news publicly
kim calls some of her closest friends to
give them a heads up
it's gonna be so hard definitely sad
i cannot ruin my makeup anymore that's
when the kkw
beauty founder reveals what her then
husband thinks about them ending the
show
what is kanye saying i mean he's like
whatever makes you happy
you know and kim says one thing that
will make her happy
is having time to work on other things
does everybody have a peek in pit
about being done
what they'll not miss what they will
miss peak of
not continuing with the show just a
little bit more free time
and then think of something else then i
won't see the crib speaking of the crew
this episode featured the moment the
famous family broke the news to the team
that the show was ending
we just wanted to tell you in person
that we won't be
going forward with filming the show
anymore shortly after the news broke in
september that keeping up would be
ending after its 20th season
e.t spoke to the show's executive
producer ryan seacrest
and he opened up about what a tough call
it was for the family to make
in talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
and i know
even you know before and after the
announcement came out
they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it as for kim she
says she knows she has to close one door
in order to open another at the end of
the day i think we all
feel like we came to this conclusion for
a reason
and we are going to ride this out and
close this chapter
and see what is on the horizon for us
next
well we know what's next the kardashians
are set to film
a new show for hulu in the near future
you